welcome folks today windy with the
Advaita Vedanta for international area
studies at Yale I am David menu a
sterling professor of political science
at least I once was and retired now and
I'm delighted to to host Susan done at
this year's set of Henry L Stimson
electric freedom we had met she I had
met we've been teaching it the way more
effort seemed pleased me in my case for
an awful long time we hadn't met but I
feel as if I met her because I've been
reading your books forever and enjoy
your books okay haha so it's but yes in
person it's great it's early there's a
strike of course I wrote Susan Susan ton
is the Massachusetts Massachusetts
professor humanities at Williams calm
waves college invest and the author a
dozen books my hand I here says dozen
Jefferson's second revolution the
election crisis of 1800 is one of them
which i wrote enjoyed that's about the
election of 1800 he has a talent for
picking important topics that elegance
about them that was a really very
important election as our colleague over
the law school robot Bruce Ackerman it's
okay to write a constitution but can you
keep it from falling apart at the
election of 1800 wasn't it sits where it
could have fallen apart they had to
comes to sub settlement because the
election was a met you think this
election is elections the best ride 1800
the real mess they have to come to some
kind of settlement and they did it as
she told us about that then my nonsense
if she got agitated yes the another book
was Roosevelt's purge how FDR fought to
change the democratic party that's
another important topic it was the
roseville 3080 this bridle disgruntled
with the democrats so he tries to kill
off a lot of them in the primaries in
1938 it didn't work but it's a very
important event
history of the New Deal and no president
has tried anything like it since it was
a lesson there then of this the prisoner
Brooklyn 1940 here's another book about
an election and again this is one of the
key elections in America history of 1940
the book is FDR wilking Lindbergh Hitler
daily election amid the storm what about
your characters those for FDR will keep
Lindbergh Hitler very heterogeneous
bunch of Harrison and this is the
setting it was a 1940 1940 the Nazis
march west they get to the Atlantic and
I guess may in 1940 the Nazis do their
egg with this up at dropped it balance
for several months and then the American
election comes down and Roosevelt has to
decide whether to run again and he does
hey Ron whoa King comes out of nowhere
to run against the bucket after I met in
that book and the ND and then the
election is a boy at least because then
the two candidates kind of converged
into big at the isolationists I mean not
exactly but so even so very important
outcome break board outcome yes then
boom now she's been here at this week is
to give us three lectures on what she
calls FDR's 3ft has third hundred days
referring back to the first other days
is very famous back in nineteen nineteen
thirty three preparing for war and Guara
global leadership dinner time span for
these three lectures is November 1940
through March 1941 the first of the
three lectures which you were here for
perhaps the other day was entitled
planned dog from isolation to a strategy
for at which time the US the US
government's got its act together they
had much of an act previously got FDR
marshal they put something together then
yesterday her reelection was a
declaration of entered
pendants that lend lease and she told us
about that this is one of the most
important legislative drives of American
national history the enactment of
lend-lease and there in the spring or a
late winter anyway of nineteen nineteen
forty one she brought us through that
mountain Asia her last lecture is
entitled the speed and speed now colon
mobilizing industry and labor for war
that's the time when they zoomed up the
army from nothing to a lot and at least
gotta go I gotta go I think that's what
that was about all those all them yeah
something like that I the funding for
thee for this lecture series the census
series comes from an anonymous donor in
honor of Henry L Stimson very important
thing during this 13 s 3 this war time
brought into the brothers run the young
Defense Department in nineteen nineteen
forty yo college 1889 was Stimson an
attorney and statesman whose government
service culminated with his tenure as
Secretary of War during World War two
unknown center again the Macmillan
Center man Yale University Press have
collaborated to bring distinguish this
diplomats and foreign policy experts to
the center to do to lecture on their
books that that come out of these
lecture series and that are published by
yo press a book will come out we'll have
it purnia Simpson lecture books have
included by Sam Huntington political
water in changing societies by Thomas
Schelling the arms n influence arms and
influence an influential book long time
ago John Donne the British political
theorists beyond the Democratic mais ma
ze and the Michael waltzer what happened
to Nash
liberation she follows in a
distinguished series and I am pleased to
introduce professor susan done thank you
very much hello again well thank you
professor may you this is definitely a
mutual admiration society in my first
two talks this week I spoke about the
transformational ideas and legislation
of Franklin Roosevelt's third hundred
days plan dog and lend lease today I'd
like to get down into the nitty-gritty
of the nation's mobilization for war in
the months between his re-election in
November 1940 and his signing of the
lend-lease act in March 41 Roosevelt
made great progress in dealing with the
extraordinary challenge of putting the
entire American economy on a wartime
basis it was a task that included three
major players labor management and
government and in it and it involved the
critical need for all of them to work
together in harmony as a team in
December 1940 a reporter for Time
magazine ventured out of the nation's
capital and wrote that leaving that in
clave was like leaving the quiet of an
office to walk into the crashing roar of
a factory the wheels of defense
industries were turning from coast to
coast and in some places around the
clock industrial plants that had been
quiet since the beginning of the
depression were buzzing again companies
that used to produce lawnmowers vacuum
cleaners textiles adding machines and
mechanical pencils were now turning out
shrapnel gas Mac gas masks mosquito
netting automatic pistols and precision
instruments
by mid-february 1941 steel mills in
Birmingham Alabama were operating at a
hundred percent capacity from the Texas
Gulf Coast to Newport News Virginia
shipyards received a billion dollars in
orders four destroyers freighters and
cargo ships for the first time in ten
years companies were investing in new
facilities for mass production new
airplane factories new chemical plants
textile mills were springing up all over
the country the United States was
unleashing all its industrial resources
and preparing for possible war and tens
of millions of Americans were
participating in this remarkable
transformation the labor force was
booming more Americans were employed
that at any then at any time since the
crash of 1929 millions of men and women
of all ages were streaming into
factories and working on assembly lines
men in the new cuffless trousers and
women wearing slacks for the first time
vocational schools were training men and
women for new roles in the workforce and
all the new workers needed places to
live they couldn't be expected to
commute long distances and they couldn't
live in tents as one government official
had proposed and so two and a half
million new homes were built along with
schools and recreational facilities and
to manage it all in July 1940 roosevelt
created a new agency called the division
of defence housing he realized that
workers morale was absolutely critical
to the defense effort the energy of all
this industrial activity was producing
prosperity in cities and towns
throughout the country communities that
had lain stagnant for years were now
expanding and thriving that oceanic
vitality built on the top of the social
and economic programs of the 1930s would
finally fulfill the promises of the New
Deal small cities like York Pennsylvania
a hundred miles west of philadelphia and
with a population of 56,000 were
becoming industrial beehives in january
41 the manager of the state employment
service in york remarked that a year ago
the task had been to find jobs for men
now the task was to find men for jobs
the search for workers was so thorough
that even old payrolls were being
checked defense contracts worth tens of
millions of dollars were pouring into
York the cities factories were turning
out tanks tank guns anti-aircraft guns
shells and trench mortars a new york
times reporter visiting york was stunned
by the changes in the lives of workers
employers merchants teachers cab drivers
sales girls and clergymen he wrote that
there was a new spirit of community and
solidarity in York and he said that
workers and employers alike talk
patriotism without getting pompous about
it and that they all spoke about the
necessity of making sacrifices by early
41 the US military had become the
biggest buyer and consumer of the
nation's industrial output and it was
also a reliable source of big profits
and yet all this massive production
wasn't enough not enough to arm the
United States for its own defense and
not enough to supply Britain with all it
needed to defend itself against Nazi
Germany production lag behind schedule
some manufacturers refused or neglected
War Department orders and as demand
exceeded supply as corporate profits
soared and as workers fought to protect
their rights the Roosevelt
administration was struggling to set up
an effective agency to oversee all
aspects of defense production
President Roosevelt recognized that such
a radical undertaking depended on
national unity and by coincidence in
early December the Economic Club of New
York held a meeting entitled national
unity for defense and invited the
president to speak at its formal dinner
at the Waldorf Astoria Roosevelt was
cruising in the Caribbean but he sent a
message to be read aloud to the eminent
guests who were the cream of the
nation's industrial and financial elite
he astutely framed his remarks about
unity under the banner of individual
rights and freedom his brand of unity
had nothing in common with the
mind-numbing fascist collectivism shoved
down the throats of the populations of
Germany and Italy FDR said plainly and I
quote there can be no real unity where
the people have no voice in a democratic
order national unity is the voluntary
expression of the mind and spirit of the
free people the freedoms that we must
and will protect in the United States
are the freedoms that will make the
individual paramount in a true democracy
Roosevelt envisage national unity in the
same way that the founding fathers did
by placing priceless value on the
freedom of the human mind an open public
debate and deliberation on due process
and individual rights he believed that
unity for the defense of American
self-government and unity for the defeat
of Nazi Germany would expand individual
freedom not limited the question then
was how to convince free rational
autonomous and self-interested citizens
to work and sacrifice for the nation's
defense and survival how to encourage a
unanimous effort without resorting to a
regimented society pitching his ideas to
the high-powered executives in the
audience the president
or perhaps his speechwriter made the
point that political freedom went hand
in hand with economic freedom and that
it was therefore crucial for government
private enterprise and labor to work
harmoniously together as partners he
emphasized that the owners of Industry
and the men and women they employed must
all receive fair and proper rewards for
their service but such unity and
cooperation would indeed turn out to be
more difficult to achieve in the United
States than in Britain probably because
British cities and industrial centers
were being bombed almost every single
night while Americans slept quietly in
their own beds and not incred at
underground shelters virtually every
aspect and every member a British
society had become organized and
disciplined for war in December 1940
Prime Minister Churchill appointed the
Menace's Minister of Labour Ernest Bevin
to serve as the head of all defense
production in Britain with the goal of
total mobilization Bevin laid down the
law everybody in this war he said has to
be a member of the working class or the
army all special privileges must
entirely disappear into the common pool
Bevin lengthened the workweek and
increased wages but he also made strikes
and lockouts illegal workers and defense
industries were forbidden to leave their
jobs without government permission and
employers couldn't fire their employees
except for misconduct men who were too
old for military service and young women
were drafted for work in war industries
that winter Columbia University's famous
historian Alan Nevins was at Oxford and
he sent an article back to the new york
times in which he described the
unprecedented centralization of
government authority in england and he
wondered how americans who still felt
safe in their homes and towns could be
persuaded that they like the British
would have to sacrifice the ordinary
habits of ordinary times first of all
industry had to play its part during the
Great Depression FDR had branded
American industrialists and finance ears
unscrupulous money changers and economic
Royalists turning them into an out group
he attacked their false leadership and
expressed satisfaction that they had
fled from their high seats in the temple
of our civilization the heroes of the
roaring 20s had become the villains of
the New Deal the age of the common man
but in 1940 the tables were turning yet
again these powerful captains of
industry were the producers the can-do
errs they knew how to make things they
owned the factories that were essential
to American defense and now FDR needed
them they would soon hitch a lucrative
ride on what would become the greatest
expansion of industrial capacity in
history but in 1940 their achievements
were neither heroic nor even adequate
manufacturers were often half-hearted in
filling defense contracts some gave
priority to more profitable consumer and
commercial orders while others wanted
guarantees against losses before they
invested in new facilities the person
ultimately in charge of making sure that
industrial production met the needs of
the American military with Secretary of
War Henry Stimson he was concerned about
bottlenecks and war production and
especially about airplane manufacturers
were too slow to convert to a wartime
footing some of these manufacturers not
only maintain their peacetime level of
production for commercial planes but
even plan to double it in 1941 in late
November Stimson held a press conference
and voiced his outrage that the
manufacturers of planes and aircraft
engines were focused on their own
profits at the expense of the war effort
which is more vital to the nation now he
asked increased military and naval
strength or increased business for
commercial airlines he publicly shamed
one company the Douglas Aircraft Company
in California for still churning out big
commercial planes while lagging two
months behind schedule in filling War
Department orders I think we put the
fear of God into the Douglas company
Stimpson hopefully wrote in his diary
and what about labor in 1940 the house
of labor was divided and subdivided on
Thanksgiving Day November 21st 1940 a
fist fight broke out in the bar of the
hotel Roosevelt in New Orleans the New
York Times young labor reporter a
Braskem was there for the annual
convention of the American Federation of
Labor the nation's largest labor union
Raskin was having a quiet drink with
David Dubinsky the respected head of the
International ladies garment workers
union when a man named Joey Fay the
tough boss of the notoriously corrupt
construction unions in New Jersey
drunkenly marched over to their table
and called Dubinsky all kinds of dirty
names for proposing anti racketeering
raloo resolutions and then he punched
Dubinsky in the face the next day
raskins account of the assault made the
front page of the New York Times while
Dubinsky for his part tried to
capitalize on the brawl to drum up
support for his anti racketeering
resolution
but the delegates at the AFL convention
agreed only that local unions should try
to expel corrupt leaders from their
ranks while the AFL was holding its
convention in New Orleans and grappling
with the problem of racketeers the CIO
was holding its own convention in
atlantic city and was grappling with the
problem of communists in its ranks and
the communists were as real and
aggressive as the AFL racketeers these
in-house clashes were harmful
distractions from the main business of
protecting the interests of union
members but far more damaging to the
nation's industrial mobilization was the
venomous rancor between the AFL and the
CIO in nineteen 40 and 41 there were
hundreds of strikes but surprisingly
many of them were not about wages or
working conditions but rather about
which of the two giant labor
organizations would win the right to
organize and represent workers in a
particular plant or industry these kinds
of strikes were called jurisdictional
strikes a very bland name for strikes
that could be vicious and long lasting
and that holds and critical work and
defense factories the AFL and the CIO
shared a very convoluted and complicated
history the American Federation of Labor
was founded in the 19th century and
retained its original character as an
alliance of small craft unions the CIO
the Congress of Industrial Organizations
included only all encompassing
industry-wide unions like the United
Mine Workers and the UAW United Auto
Workers the CIO had been born inside the
AFL in 1935 but in 1938 the labor
leaders who had created
the CIO took it out of the AFL and now
there were two rival labor giants that
were blood enemies but in nineteen forty
one of the CIO founders david Dubinsky
was upset with the dictatorial style of
the cio luton leader john l Lewis the
President of the United Mine Workers and
so Dubinsky took the ladies garment
workers union back to the AFL and that
move ignited even more bitterness
between the AFL and the CIO President
Roosevelt and his labor secretary
Frances Perkins had tried repeatedly to
narrow the rift between the two major
labor organizations pleading with their
leaders to find a way to restore unity
and harmony to organized labor or as
they said at least to come up with a
sensible working arrangement the AFL
president was willing to cooperate and
meet with cio Representatives but CIO
leaders were intransigent and slammed
the door shut they insisted that that
there could be no unity in the labor
movement only when except when the AFL
surrendered to the CIO and accepted the
cios model of a single union
representing an entire industry
stalemate the rivalry between the two
labor giants resulted in fierce
unionization campaigns and walkouts but
some strikes really were about wages and
working conditions the Roosevelt
administration had always strongly
backed labor rights and working people
always had a place of honor in FDR's
coalition in 1935 the bond between the
White House and labor produced the
National Labor Relations Act also known
as the Wagner Act after decades of harsh
struggles workers finally won the right
to organize and unions and engage in
collective bargaining with the national
government playing referee to
sure an equitable playing field the
Roosevelt administration was on labor
side until the crisis year of 1940 then
the administration began to see things
differently and viewed work stoppages as
threats to the nation's survival one
highly disruptive walk out in late 1940s
traited the new complexities in
industrial production 5,000 workers at
the vaulty aircraft company plant in
california went on strike and halted
work on defense orders for military
planes during the previous five months
hundreds of labor disputes had taken
place all over the country though most
lasted just a few hours or a few days
but the strike at vaulty went on for a
month workers were demanding a 25 cent
increase in the 50 cent hourly wage so
that their wage would be the same as
employees doing similar work in
automobile factories even Eleanor
Roosevelt way then about the vaulty
strike in her mind a newspaper column
she asked why workers were expected to
accept low wages and long hours for the
sake of national defense when management
wasn't willing to cut profits and
executive salaries her verdict was that
sacrifices have to be equal after all
industry was booming profits escalating
corporate executives pocketing enormous
salaries and labor wanted a fair piece
of the pie War Department officials went
to the vaulty headquarters to help
mediate the conflict and finally after
days of tense negotiations the strike
was over workers won a pay raise more
paid vacation time and an annual sick
leave and in exchange they accepted a
no-strike clause and agreed to resolve
future disputes with an arbitration
board in the end the clash at volte
proved relatively easy to settle workers
had strong
union representation management agreed
to negotiate with union leaders and
govern mediation succeeded during FDR's
third hundred days more than 300 highly
disruptive strikes took place whether
they were jurisdictional disputes or
wage disputes they all slowed down
defense production and so on March
nineteenth nineteen forty one roosevelt
created by executive order the national
defense mediation board its mission was
to settle strikes in defense industries
first by facilitating collective
bargaining and failing that by
participating in mediation and as a last
resort by proposing binding arbitration
the mediation board proved highly
effective in reducing the number and
length of strikes and by the end of 1941
it had resolved over a thousand walkouts
but when labor and management both
rejected arbitration Roosevelt in his
role as commander-in-chief could direct
the army to take over a plant Congress
had given the administration what
amounted to control over the nation's
defense industries one section of the
1940 Selective Service Act was known as
the Russell overton amendment senators
Overton of Louisiana and Russell of
Georgia reasoned that if the government
could draft young men it should also be
able to draft industry it authorized the
government to take over the factories of
any companies that didn't cooperate a
national defense and in 1941 the
President did indeed command the War
Department to take over the operations
of several airplane factories where
strikes were tying up production on
thousands of military planes there was
another serious challenge concerning
labor management and government the
owners of some very large manufacturing
company
simply refused to allow their workers to
unionize and this presented Roosevelt
with a very thorny problem yes the
Wagner Act had given workers the right
to unionize opening the door to mass
unionization but the administration
urgently needed the production
capabilities of those union-busting
companies and so it felt it had no
choice but to give them large defense
contracts the most defiant industrial
industrialist was none other than the
elderly Henry Ford the inventor of the
assembly line and the father of mass
production not only did Ford a notorious
anti-semite run factories in Germany
that produced military vehicles for the
Nazi army ford also believed that the
British Empire was a doomed and unworthy
cause and in june nineteen forty ford
refused to accept a government contract
to manufacture plane engines for the
royal air force for years ford had
violated labor laws and resisted the
right of its workers to be represented
by the UAW the company even had a
so-called service department that
employed thugs who regularly and
brutally beat up union organizers a nine
different occasions the National Labor
Relations Board had found Ford guilty of
violating the Wagner Act it was an
appalling record but there was no other
company in the US that had such massive
and modern production facilities for
example Ford's gigantic river rouge
plant in Dearborn Michigan measured one
and a half miles by one mile it
comprised 93 buildings and had its own
docks mill and electric plant as well as
a private railroad track that wove in
and out of its many buildings Ford Motor
was so important to national defense
that FDR
and Secretary of War Stimson decided to
put Ford's anti union activities behind
them and concentrate on persuading Ford
to play fair with labor in the future
and so in November nineteen forty six
months after Ford rejected that
government contract for plane engines
for the RAF and just one month after a
federal appeals appeals court found Ford
guilty of igniting a labor riot at one
of its plants the War Department awarded
Ford and Ford accepted a hundred and
twenty million dollar contract for more
than four thousand engines this time all
for the American army and navy but in
the spring of 41 Ford's relations with
its labor force changed abruptly in
March afford official vowed that the
company would meet with you aww
representatives when hell freezes over
and that workers wouldn't get a damn
thing well three months later hell froze
over the president of Ford Motor was
Henry Ford son Edsel Edsel was often
overruled by his father but he was
better grounded in reality he wasn't
deaf to patriotism and he wasn't blind
to the opportunities for tremendous
profits and defense contracts in June 41
Ford finally surrendered to the UAW and
gave the Union virtually everything it
asked for the company agreed to pay a
wage equal to the highest in the
industry and to abolish the company's
goon squad and the payoff was huge by
December 7th 1941 Ford held government
contracts worth over 300 million dollars
which today would be five billion
dollars other anti-union corporations
followed for its lead in 1941 six years
after Congress
past the Wagner Act companies like
Bethlehem Steel Westinghouse and
international harvester finally
recognized their workers rights to
unionize and that year union membership
grew by one and a half million workers
and now let's move on to the complicated
role of government in defense production
it alone could set priorities award
contracts balance domestic and foreign
orders make sure that strategic raw
materials like aluminum and zinc were
available oversee transportation of
weapons and help settle labor disputes
that was a tremendously complex endeavor
for example most industries marked their
own orders a one priority so that ninety
percent of all defense orders fell in
the a one priority which really meant
that there were no priorities at all
procurement posed another problem
because the army had neither experts nor
experience in knowing what products to
buy or how to buy them in the spring of
nineteen forty Roosevelt had established
the National Defense Advisory Commission
the ndac to bring order to this chaos
but FDR granted it only limited
authority so the ndac simply added to
the disorder that it was supposed to
subdue Secretary of War Stimson was the
first to realize that the ndac was a
failure he understood better than anyone
else the urgent need for a powerful new
agency that could cut red tape award
contracts oversee production and resolve
labor disputes when he met with
Roosevelt right after roosevelt's
lend-lease garden hose press conference
in mid-december they agreed about the
ineffectiveness of the NDA C and began
to form a plan to replace it at a press
conference in late December FDR told
reporters that he would soon be sure
hang up the whole defense structure he
said that he would issue an executive
order establishing a new office for
production management according to that
executive order the new OPM would have
vast Authority and I quote to formulate
and execute all measures to necessary to
increase the production of everything
required for national defense and to
ensure effective coordination of
government industry and labor that was
big FDR established the OPM in January
41 and it was another crucial step in
his third hundred days the OPM had three
main branches one dealt with procurement
and contracts the second would oversee
management and the third would deal with
labor some officials in the War
Department complained that labor should
have been granted only an unofficial
advisory role but both Roosevelt and
Stimpson understood the preparations for
war and mobilization of all the nation's
defense industries would depend almost
completely on American workers stimson
declared that labor represented the
backbone of defense and that labor would
be an equal and respected partner with
industry in March 41 the Senate created
its own committee chaired by Missouri's
Harry Truman to act as a watchdog over
the National Defense program the Truman
committee scrutinized defense contracts
investigated industry corruption and
uncovered government mismanagement and
waste and it did all that in order to
reassure Americans that the defense
build-up was not a riot of profiteering
corruption excessive government spending
and in competence as it had been to some
extent in world war one but the Truman
committee still found plenty of problems
for example Truman's investigation into
the army
construction program led to a complete
overhaul of all phases of that program
his committee exposed companies that
were selling defective material to the
government and it brought the hammer
down on businesses making excessive
profits on defense contracts some of
those embarrassed firms one redemption
by cutting executive salaries to near
nothing and eliminating profits from
production and offering workers
attractive salaries and bonuses a few
large companies like GE and eastman
kodak voluntarily turned over a part of
their profits to government but Truman
nevertheless remarked and i quote labor
feels it owes a duty to labor business
feels that it owes a duty to
stockholders but both often fail to
realize that the duty they owe is to the
country ultimately cooperation between
labor management and government worked
remarkably well big business was coming
on board the members of FDR's
administration were finally finding
common ground with the powerful men they
had announced in 1936 and responsible
union leaders made a no-strike pledge to
the president those strikes did continue
some workers were lackadaisical there
were cases of greedy management and
outright fraud in industry and there
were plenty of disputes between civilian
and military officials the war crisis
didn't change human nature or abolish
self-interest but the sheer might of
American industry nevertheless made the
United States the greatest producer of
armaments the world had ever known
together Labor and Industry produced a
vast flood of war material without
compromising labor unions workers rights
or the profit-making free enterprise
system democracy in America hardly had
to trim its sales I found a few songs
from
the early 1940s that celebrated the
contributions that unions and all
Americans made to the war effort since
I'm tone-deaf I'm not going to sing them
but these are the lyrics to one UAW song
the UAW CIO makes the army roll and go
turning out the jeeps and tanks and
airplanes every day putting wheels on
the USA there'll be a union label in
Berlin when the Union boys and uniform
march in and here are the lyrics from a
song from the 1942 Cole Porter musical
Panama Hattie oh capital may take a
while up at labor the CIO may slug the
AFL though our melting pot may boil
red-hot with a thousand different types
though we lefties and righties may have
our fights we all stand pat on the
no-good rat who belittles the Stars and
Stripes that's available on YouTube at
the end of Roosevelt's third hundred
days in march 41 the united states was
neither fully at peace nor fully at war
and the president himself was not fully
reconciled to unrestricted american
involvement in the war he remained
reluctant to move too far ahead of
public opinion even though a majority of
americans had come to embrace his
internationalist leadership he believed
the country needed more time to rearm
and he told his close aides that he was
waiting for some major provocation to
push him into war he had effectively
boxed himself into a policy of all aid
to Britain short of war and yet despite
his caution Franklin Roosevelt's third
hundred days constituted one of the most
fertile periods in his long presidency
three winter months during which his
administration rejected neutrality and I
exhalation approved crucial preparations
for war made a commitment to victory and
put in focus and in motion the means
necessary to achieve that victory from
December 1940 through March 41 he made
for the first time speeches and press
conferences to reorient American foreign
policy in a frankly internationalist
direction he educated Americans about
the challenge that the nation and the
world faced he laid out his policies and
the motivating causes and values behind
them and he spoke about the sacrifices
he would ask his fellow citizens to make
in order to achieve the paramount goal
of defeating germany all of which had
previously been only half spoken by the
end of march planned dog the ABC talks
that provided a forum for Anglo british
military collaboration lend-lease the
shift to a wartime economy and the
prodigious acceleration of defense
production were all irrevocably underway
though Roosevelt made no public
declaration of intention all of this
amounted to a covert declaration of war
those winter months also marked a shift
in the national consciousness a decisive
irreversible step out of the past and
into the future in January 1941
Roosevelt's four freedoms address began
to articulate his vision for the
post-war world beyond the destruction of
Nazi Germany he pictured an era that
would see American ascendancy across
military political social economic
cultural and moral realms that vision of
America's dominant global role and
emerged during FDR's third hundred days
on August ninth 1941 a conference began
aboard the American Cruiser Augusta
anchored in placencia Bay on the coast
of Newfoundland Roosevelt had traveled
there for secret meetings with Winston
Churchill the two men greeted each other
warmly the Prime Minister was
desperately hoping for an american
declaration of war instead he received
the consolation prize of almost
unlimited access to American weapons
what Roosevelt wanted from Churchill was
less tangible than rifles tanks and
planes he came seeking a joint statement
of where the two allies stood in terms
of their war aims and also a declaration
to the world of what the two allies
stood for their landmark statement would
be known as the Atlantic Charter
Roosevelt considered it a path to global
cooperation and peacekeeping as well as
a path to human rights everywhere in the
world the two nations pledged to forsake
territorial expansion to permit
territorial changes only when the people
concerned approved them and to make sure
that self-government was restored to
those who had been forcibly deprived of
it that was a clause that applied not
only to the victims of the axis but also
to people living under European
colonialism and indeed it would inspire
independence movements in European
colonies around the world the Charter
also made explicit reference to two of
FDR's four freedoms freedom from want
and freedom from fear Roosevelt and
Churchill hope to create and I quote
world peace that will afford to all
nations the means of dwelling and safety
within their own boundaries so that all
men in all lands may live out their
lives and freedom from fear and freedom
from want for
Roosevelt the charter represented not
just a symbolic gesture it was a
commitment to a common human fraternity
Roosevelt was the dominant partner had
the meeting in placenta obey he didn't
give Britain what Churchill most wanted
though he obtained from Churchill what
he most wanted yet aboard the Augusta
the two men formed a genuine working
friendship one that set the tone for
anglo-american cooperation amid the
whirlwind of war a world tragedy had
brought them together and now they
walked the long and stark road toward
the future together well I've always
been pre punctual and I finished writing
that conclusion that was my conclusion I
finished writing that conclusion about
the Atlantic Charter last summer on July
first that day I heard on the news that
it was the hundredth anniversary of the
beginning of the five month long battle
of the somme in northern France when
that battle ended in November 1916 they
were about a hundred and fifty thousand
dead three hundred thousand wounded and
countless more psychically maimed that
day last July was also one week after
the brexit vote in the United Kingdom a
vote that seemed to me to unravel the
ties that helped give stability and
harmony to the European nations that had
suffered utter devastation in two world
wars the brexit vote was a triumph for
British isolationists and on July first
it was a day when Donald Trump as usual
made his vow to make America great again
by building walls and dismantling
alliances when he adopted the toxic 1940
isolationist slogan America
first and boasted about his good
European jeans and when he railed
against immigrants and free trade I
thought things were as bad as they could
get not so today we face the ominous
possibility that the post-war
international system might collapse
Trump himself predicted that his
election victory would be brexit times
10 our Donald Trump marine lepen and
brexit the wave of the future and so as
some of our fellow Americans retreat
into nativism and xenophobia as they
call for closed borders and restricted
trade and practice unrestricted
religious and racial prejudice I thought
we should turn to our Yale graduate
Henry Stimson for help his 1947 article
in foreign affairs entitled the
challenge to Americans speaks to us
today and I'll close this talk with his
words this nation must put away forever
any thought that America can again be an
island unto herself no private program
and no public policy in any sector of
our national life can now escape from
the compelling fact that if it is not
framed with reference to the world it is
framed with perfect futility our stake
in the peace and freedom of the world is
not a limited liability time after time
in the past we have tried to solve our
foreign problems with halfway measures
acting under the illusion that we could
be partly in the world and partly
irresponsible I have served a Secretary
of State under President Hoover in a
time of frightened isolationism and a
secretary of war under President
Franklin Roosevelt in a time of brave
and generous action I know the withering
effect of limited commitments and I know
the reach
generative power of full action the
attitude of isolationism political or
economic must die the vain hope that we
can live alone must be abandoned it is
evident that we cannot do everything
we'd like but it would be a shriveling
timidity for Americans to refuse to play
their full and necessary part in the
world all men good and bad are now our
neighbors freedom demands tolerance and
many Americans have much to learn about
the variety of forms that free societies
may take we must act in the world as it
is and not in the world as we wish it
were or even as we would like it to
become it is a world in which we are
only one people out of many and in which
our basic principles of freedom equality
and due process are not shared by all
our neighbors but Americans must now
understand that the United States has
become for better or for worse a wholly
committed member of the world community
that is a plain fact our only choice is
whether or not to face it I'll end my
talk here and I thank Henry Stimson for
his wise and timely words and for
holding my hand this week and I thank
all of you
you